now Asian countries that have been
suffering from extreme heat in recent
weeks are bracing for another challenge
rice a staple of the region could be in
short supply as a dry spell looms
scientists have developed climate
resilient varieties but Farmers say they
cost more to produce Barnaby law reports
from Nueva ejisa in the Philippines
with no irrigation system Eduardo Mateos
rice fields rely on rainfall but the
past weeks have been extremely hot
weather experts are predicting a dry
spell this month due to a climate
pattern known as El Nino
the government has provided Eduardo with
drought persistent seeds but he says
they're still going to need water
we have to buy fuel to be able to pump
water sometimes we have to get a loan
from the bank and risk our home getting
foreclosed farmers in the Philippines
are warning not only of higher prices
but a meager Harvest while the
Philippines does produce rice it relies
heavily on Imports last year the
government bought a 3.7 million tons but
Supply is slow with rice production
across the region suffering from rising
temperatures and a prolonged drought
economists say that's likely to worsen
inflation especially as rice exporting
countries like India and Thailand could
curb shipments
the international rice Research
Institute says warmer nights have
resulted in annual losses of about 2.3
million tons of rise across Asia during
the last two decades
scientists have been working hard on
developing rights that can survive
higher temperatures we have identified
genetic regions responsible for improved
yield under highlight temperature and
using that knowledge we have now
developed some varieties of Rices which
give Optimum yield under high Knife
temperature compared to other checks and
it's not only the heat that's a
challenge climate change has also
triggered record amounts of rainfall in
countries like Pakistan where nearly 400
000 hectares of rice fields were damaged
by unprecedented floods last year
I think climate change is a direct
threat to our food security there are
new diseases emerging new pests are
attacking the crops and making huge
losses these things are suddenly
happening and we are not prepared for it
this Gene back inside the international
rice Research Institute should offer
hope more than 130 000 varieties and
sub-varieties have been kept here and
for decades they've helped the world
cope with a changing climate before and
they're aiming to release new heat
tolerant varieties by next year Barn
below Al Jazeera Nueva ecija the
Philippines